does it count if there's like a mimic
like a mimic mimicking fasting by doing
like a keto coffee kind of thing is that
something that would still be considered
like breaking the fast like at 12 hours
i have you know
butter in my coffee mct whatever
something like that
if it has calories it counts as food
if you are
doing let's say an overnight
intermittent fast and then breaking that
fast let's say 12 hours in with uh let's
like use it like a keto coffee you know
coffee with butter and stuff in it
yeah technically that is going to
give your endocrine system a signal that
you're not in starvation mode and that
calories are present
some
kind of like slightly orthorexic ish
women will take this to mean that they
can just fast until lunchtime as long as
they put a minuscule teaspoon of mct oil
in their morning coffee and that's not
what i'm saying what i'm saying is that
you can you don't have to eat a huge
breakfast but
get some calories in your system within
that 12-hour window if you can you know
i wouldn't be doing a lot of
intermittent fasting without giving your
body something past those 12 hours
another good strategy is like and this
is what i like for people who just want
to crush a morning workout without
eating a huge breakfast would just be
use essential amino acids and mix those
with ketones and like ketones mixed with
essential amino acids is really great
for like a a low calorie scenario but a
scenario in which you still want to
support like a hard exercise session and
have your body have some some
nutrients to rely upon for energy and
then i i would say as you have been
doing most of your carbohydrates for the
evening just to keep your body in kind
of like a fatty acid metabolizing status
most of the day then you have all your
carbs in the evening spark the serotonin
the melatonin production and then
basically be able to sleep well after
that as far as exercise goes when i sit
down and i work on an exercise protocol
for somebody i'm looking at you know how
many days you have available how many
how many hours what are previous
injuries are you trying to lose fat gain
muscle etc etc but i i can tell you and
this is similar to what i what i kind of
outline in the boundless book is
you know for for most people and this is
very similar to what i do for like a
stay healthy for life type of exercise
protocol
you want to include
some type of strength session some type
of mitochondrial triggering session
something that would trigger vo2 max
something that triggers lactate
tolerance something for mobility
something for balance and something for
long-term endurance and so what that
would look like for example would be
three times a week a full body heavy
strength training session with anywhere
from three to five sets of somewhere in
the range of four to ten repetitions of
heavy full body weights no messing
around the body part split programs you
know chest day and shoulder day and calf
abs day and bicep spleen kidney or liver
pancreas day whatever just just like
full body exercise session three times a
week for the module for the
mitochondrial component one session
where you're doing really really hard 20
to 30 second efforts followed by long
recovery periods and that can be thrown
in before or after any of those strength
training sessions or on a different day
for the vo2 max piece something where
you're pushing yourself for a longer
period of time than 20 to 30 seconds and
for vo2 max preferably two to four
minutes
where you're doing let's say like a
classic vo2 training protocol would be
like five rounds of five hard minutes on
the air dyne each separated by five
minutes of active recovery and that
would be something you could do once a
week as well
for the lactate tolerance in addition to
the strength the mitochondria and the
vo2 something like a tabata set where
you're training your body to tolerate
high levels of lactic acid by doing four
minutes of 20 seconds hard 10 seconds
easy
and that would be like two to three
times a week and again that could come
before or after one of those strength
training sessions or on a different day
of the week for the fat burning piece i
recommend one time per week like a
longer somewhat fasted or
exercise session in which you're you're
not eating a ton before the exercise
session but you're burning a lot of fats
this would be
like waking up you know let's say you
wake up you've been fasting and it's 5
00 a.m and you do like a two-hour hike
then come back and have your first meal
of the day but that you don't overdo
that like an over trained ironman
triathlete would that's just like once a
week you're doing like a longer
lower
cardio aerobic exercise session without
a lot of calories on board so you're
training your fat burning capacity
mobility and balance you know 10 to 15
minutes of foam rolling every morning
and something like a massage you know
once every week or two
and then for the balance component i
mean i i just weave that into my
workouts where i'll do stuff standing on
one leg you know brush my teeth standing
on one leg or you know my breaks in
between my calls in my office i'll do a
few balance exercises but basically if
you check the boxes of strength
mitochondria and mitochondria again is
short bursts of energy followed by long
recovery periods
vo2 max which are those longer kind of
surges of exercise followed by longer
recovery periods
lactate tolerance which is just like
build up a [ __ ] ton of lactic acid then
back off with something like a tabata
set uh that longer fat burning session
once a week
mobility and balance thrown in every day
and and you know i kind of flesh this
out in really good detail and i think
it's the longevity chapter in boundless
where i talk about the perfect exercise
program to kind of like stay fit for
life that works for a lot of people
that's generally kind of like the
overview of what it would look like and
then in addition to that include you
know being outside barefoot getting lots
of sunshine doing a sauna session a few
times a week preferably with some kind
of intense cold afterwards
and then um just low level movement
throughout the day you know walking a
lot taking breaks you know during your
during your work day to crank out some
push-ups or kettlebell swings or
whatever and i mean what i've just
described to you is pretty close to what
i do especially since i hung up the
competitive exercise hat and i feel like
i'm as fit and even more healthy than i
was you know when i was doing iron man
triathlon and spartan races and all this
crazy stuff but it's just those three
key strength training sessions a week
low level physical activity throughout
the day hitting mitochondria lactic acid
and vo2 max on a regular basis
a little bit of mobility and balance
sauna cold and uh sunshine and grounding
and that's basically kind of like a an
overview of what like a really really
decent movement protocol for for a lot
of people is going to look like i have
juve red light behind you um i have you
know a little sauna i don't have the big
big one i have just like a pop-up one
but it gets like 135 i don't have a cold
plunge my pool's pretty cold right now
or my shower is cold i suppose which is
definitely not nearly as cold as a cold
plunge is there a specific order of
frequency for those red light panels if
you have them would be early in the
morning or in the evening before
uh like before dinner to simulate
sunrise and sunset your body's really
really receptive of those red light
frequencies at those two times of day in
terms of circadian rhythmicity there's
the sauna and the cold i really like
those again either in the morning you
know so many mornings of the week i'll
wake up and my morning
exercise session if you want to call it
that is like 30 minutes in the sauna
then two to five minutes of cold and
then i'll save any hard you know
typically i'll do like a 30 to 45 minute
exercise session later in the day but
that's like in the afternoon when grip
strength peaks and testosterone peaks
and reaction time peaks and strength
peaks and you're just more favorably
suited to doing the hard workout later
on in the day and in the morning like
the sauna plus the cold or an easy walk
in the sunshine barefoot or something
along those lines i heard you say one
time a week do like a longer sort of
couple hour hike maybe something that's
not super crazy but gets you into fat
burning
what about so is that are you saying i
should eat first every day like i should
eat before i work out or
the other days and does walking is
walking considered um working out like a
lot of times i'll take the dogs for a
walk and then i'll come back and
eat the main takeaway for you
is
that
if you have gone longer than 12 hours
without eating whether or not you're
exercising you should eat if you are up
at 6 00 a.m you finish dinner at 8 00 pm
it's been 10 hours you want to go work
out fine go go do it you don't need to
eat anything before but if it's like you
know 10 a.m and all you've had is like
your coffee with a little bit of butter
in it and you know you're gonna go out
and let's say the morning time is when
you decide to do your vo2 max and your
strength training session i wouldn't be
messing around too much with like the
harder fasted workout so just try to as
a general rule not go longer than 12
hours without eating and try to as a
general rule not do hard fasted morning
workouts sauna
cold walking etc i would not classify
for you as something that you're going
to need to like go out of your way to
feed yourself beforehand
unless again it's a scenario where it's
been 12 plus hours in which case i'd do
like you know
10 20 grams of essential amino acids and
a shot of ketones or just something
that's like a small trigger so that your
body's not going in super depleted